don't cut the cameras off this is a1
content this is what this is all about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by andrew callahan
he's a journalist you know best from his
work on channel 5 news which ranges from
gonzo profiles of florida man folk
heroes to boots on the ground field
pieces in war-torn ukraine i'm a channel
5 news subscriber i definitely recommend
you check it out but first things first
the wings of death andrew callahan
welcome to the show thank you so much
man i'm a huge fan whoa all right it's
an honor to be on here how are you
around spicy food before we talk i'm not
a spice guy
i'm not a scared guy i'm not too
frightened of the spicy wings but i'm
when i think about level five level six
that might be my ko
[Music]
so we start from the left right this is
level one over here oh cause if i [ __ ]
this up yeah yeah can we say the f word
on this show yeah you can let it flap
this up then you know but you were about
to [ __ ] that that's level actually yeah
you actually do start on the other side
okay at the handle
[Music]
[Music]
i ate the whole thing i saw that no it
was safe to behold yeah dude to see that
nice yeah you gotta see that i noticed
it live i eat the juicy bone marrow off
the end of it
i'm ready
so man on the street liked the interview
it's a timeless conceit that seems to
constantly evolve with the changing
times and platforms in your approach
it's birthed an entire genre of these
kind of meme bait on location man on the
street style interview shows yeah when
you see the imitations what are the
things that you watch that make you
proud to have blazed that trail and then
what are the things that annoy you the
most when you see them well i mean like
the first thing i want to say is that
when i see imitation channels like i try
to avoid being the salty old guy because
i'm only 20. i'm only 25 years old like
i'm sure there's people that are
interviewing other people with hot wings
and such but i was i get really stoked
when other countries do it like there's
this show called shibuya confessions
which is pretty much modeled directly
off my original quarter confession
series in new orleans that i used to do
on bourbon street it's like so funny
it's like this dude speaking japanese in
shibuya in tokyo like interviewing drunk
party goers at like two o'clock in the
morning in full japanese like drunk old
man singing karaoke late night that's
hilarious uh when people do like
ultra mean bait like screaming mouth
zooms with just like not much substance
to it and they just try to get people to
scream incoherently that kind of bums me
out so when i see i'm not gonna call
anybody out but certain successful other
shows
i feel like are a little bit more
exploitative
yeah
[Music]
it's not even spicy bro level two
already talking [ __ ] no
i'm struggling with eating the wing
itself it doesn't look like you're
struggling it looks like you know you're
putting on an exhibition putting a show
with eaten wings that's how it looks
yeah all right good andrew a showman
that's what i do man
so sometimes we joke about the set the
hot one set being like a relic from an
80s cable access show right do you have
any thoughts or guiding philosophy when
it comes to aesthetic and how it plays
into the interview medium just as low
effort as possible that's what they did
best when like the public access 80s
days it's like don't use after effects
don't even think about it
you know imovie transitions go pretty
hard
just crash zooms cross dissolves fade to
black dip to white
you know just get to that next frame by
any means explosions and fireballs being
a segue between two very different plot
points all right well we'll put uh we'll
put colin on that we'll do some sort of
explosion that's what i'm all about
fireballs
it spices up everything
even level two
from oaxaca
okay
so there are all these different
approaches to taking a camera pointing
it at the rawness of humanity and
exposing it warts and all what would you
say distinguishes someone like sasha
baron cohen from someone like louie
thoreau and then where do you think you
fall on that spectrum well louis thoreau
is a big inspiration because he follows
what i call like radical listening which
is just approach a situation as
open-minded as possible and just agree
with the interviewer subtly like a
toddler called the toddler not it's like
you're not like yes you're so right
brother but you're just like
letting it build
i think sasha baron cohen's more like a
straight up prankster they're both
masters of their respective crafts but
louis thoreau is the biggest inspiration
to me because he's just so open-minded
and caring and just trying to empathize
and connect with whoever he can even if
it's like someone super far out there
yeah louise louisa g for that as someone
who's explored so many fringe
subcultures and groups is there one in
particular that stands out to you as
being the most misrepresented or
misunderstood by the rest of us yeah i
think the furries are very
misrepresented all right i'm on the edge
of my seat they're a kind uh very
empathetic group of people you know what
i mean a lot of them are on the spectrum
struggle with various identity issues
and the fursuit allows them to sort of
revert to that like playful childhood
vibe where they can just interact with
people without having to make eye
contact because the first suit covers
that because when i went to the midwest
fur fest
shout out
rosemont illinois convention center baby
here we go right off the blue line yeah
you know what i'm talking about so when
i first went there like i was asking
like you know
more sexual furry questions because i
didn't know what to expect and this
furry pulled me aside and he's like yo
that's not what this is about this is
about love and respect and having good
fursuits and holding each other down
then boom i was like all right
furry gang
have you met a furry before no i've
never met a furry but if they do that uh
annually in rosemont i gotta check it
out yeah go back home and check it out
you should get a fursuit of your own
costs about thirty seven hundred dollars
well that's right dom
make it a line item
i'm glad this one this one's a flat
[Music]
gotta eat the whole thing i know can't
tap out not a spice guy but just
crushing the whole wing taking down the
bone marrow and all yeah cause one day
my grandkids are gonna see this and
wonder
what grampy andrew could handle i gotta
set a good example for those kids
so you have a fascinating origin story
more or less deciding on a whim to quit
your job and hitchhike across the
country for 70 straight days without
much of a plan or goal it or anything
did you have any sort of harrowing oh my
god my life might be in danger when you
think about the bus stations and cd
motels that you spent so many hours in
yeah uh my first ride ever
which was from a arco gas station in
crowley louisiana to houston i was
mistaken for a lot lizard are you
familiar with that term is that like is
that like a prostitute thing it's a
semi-derogatory trucker term for someone
who hangs out in a large trucker parking
lot and solicits services to truckers
so i'm chilling there with a bunch of
other good-looking young guys and i'm
thinking they're adventurers like me you
know they're like jack kerouac-minded
hippie kind of guys all of a sudden this
like really messed up 1991 honda civic
like a broken windshield no back windows
pulls up and this little honduran dude
wearing all leather super super leather
daddy outfit he's like hey get inside
i get in we're driving like 45 minutes
and he goes like do you like movies and
i was like yeah i like movies i was like
[ __ ] let's talk about movies then he was
like do you like porn and i was like all
right this is getting kind of weird but
i was like i'm trying to be agreeable
because i don't want him to kick me out
of the car for some reason
dude i love porn bro it's my favorite
[ __ ] in the world
the moment i said that i liked porn he
took the nearest freeway exit and he
took us to this weird renovated
farmhouse there was six confessional
booths
inside the confessional booths were like
little tv screens with like three
different porn channels on it so it's
like a weird creepy thing and he's like
you want to watch it together and i was
like no i think i'm good bro like i'm
just gonna watch this by myself you do
your thing i'll do my thing and then
we'll just meet back outside and keep
going and he was like why were you at
that truck stop and i was like i'm just
a you know hitchhiker trying to explore
america and get to know my home country
and he's like oh you shouldn't have been
there bro like that's like a hooker
truck stop
and i was like okay that's all good i'm
not a hooker and he was like all right
that's all good and he drove me all the
way to houston oh yeah that's kind of a
cool move by him yeah but there was a
couple seconds where i was scared i was
like this guy's gonna [ __ ] kill me i
gotta get out of here but not he was
like okay honest mistake and he we
proceeded onward so
shout out to that man
[Music]
this one's freaking hard
[Music]
incredible
incredible that's what we do man
all right andrew while you enjoy that
marrow we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that graham we
do a deep dive on our guest instagram
pull interesting pictures
that need more context oh fantastic so
we'll pull the picture up over here on
the monitor you just tell us the bigger
story
how would you describe the sights and
sounds of the capitol hill autonomous
zone in seattle i'm from capitol hill
seattle you know i pretty much grew up
in and around this park cal anderson
park
so to see that on the news it was its
own country that was ran by a warlord
according to fox news i flew home got
off the light rail at the capitol hill
station walked up and you know basically
saw every person that i grew up with
you know
had formed their own country i lived in
a tent in the chop for like two weeks
what was that like it was interesting my
tent got stolen three times
chop was a really fascinating uh you
know social experiment
i witnessed like a really bad shooting
on one of the last days of chop the day
after the shooting a lot of the medics
and staff decided it was too dangerous
and so a lot of them left
and so that last four days of chop
before the cops came and took it back
was pretty lawless
well at least you got to spend some time
there you know yeah
all right one more for you
what do you remember about running into
anthony weiner at target yeah i was in
target buying some white claws for my
aunt in manhattan and i i saw carlos
danger in there with some pit vipers on
and i was like anthony weiner
and he like looked at me he thought i
was gonna like you know record him and
be like what do you have to say for
yourself the dick pics are outrageous
but no he didn't he was like what's up i
was like huge fan because i didn't know
what to say i was like can i get a pic
and then i snapped this and then you
know i walked off he looks pretty upset
in this picture i would say
[Laughter]
so i've heard that sometimes you put the
spiciest wing before level 10 to elicit
an extreme reaction and this says
collards and ghost and i know that ghost
is a freaking spicy pepper so i think
you might be trying to swindle me and
create some sort of breakdown but i'm
going to go for it but i know the ghost
is serious ghost is is that the spiciest
pepper so but maybe you don't even know
what's going on ghost is not as hot as
carolina reaper so he might be playing
all kinds of mind tricks on you listen
i'm not backing down but i see what's
going on
oh jesus christ
i'm almost done gotta finish this like a
jeep look at that
going in
[Music]
crushing it
grandkids are going to be proud they
truly are man damn level six
accomplished uh there we go they can't
take that away it's hitting my tongue
so it's never not surreal to me that
this goofy chicken wing production has
grown to become one of the biggest talk
shows in the entire world but i don't
think that we could be having that kind
of conversation if not for legacy media
companies constantly perpetually
misreading and failing their own
audiences right do you ever think about
how much of your own success might be
the result of the american news media
machine's own neglect
yeah i think that if walter cronkite was
on tv
people might not want to watch channel 5
as much
but i think the void created
by
legacy and center right and center-left
mainstream media
constantly competing for shock reactions
from their respective audiences has
created a void
that allows people like you and i to do
more numbers than the traditional news
media outlets because nobody wants to
watch that
both sides of mainstream media try so
hard to create this ultimate like
domestic enemy whether it's like
mainstream liberal media telling you
that like there's these insane neo-nazi
contingents that are surrounding every
major city trying to kill everyone or if
it's like you know center uh right media
being like antifa and black lives matter
are gonna come to your house in branson
missouri and burn your farm down you
know like i don't wanna i'm not hating
on rural people i'm just saying like
that's what they say because they know
their audience you know and also there's
lots of misrepresentations of the south
you know classic tropes about the south
being the place of the problem
from
from
center left media then on center right
media there's talking about california
is like this third world [ __ ] and
it's not it just has problems like
everywhere else and it's just kind of
scary because
people really think that there's like
this boogeyman
on the other side of the political
spectrum and there definitely is if
you're looking for it but most people
are just more concerned with their
day-to-day life they don't have time to
participate in the political theater
that we saw unfold
in 2020.
where's this one from
south dakota
let's get in there
should i do it
yeah i'll do it too when i slam in the
mirror let's slam some mirror
oh yeah that's good merrell
i see that in there we go
so i don't even know if you're a food
guy but your rv travels are like a food
lover's fantasy right what to you is the
best regional fast food chain
i think that uh bucky's in texas
it's a gas station chain they have like
the best pulled pork and brisket
sandwiches that stuff is so good do you
have an all-time favorite roadside
attraction that you've ever discovered
off an interstate i like the clown motel
in tenopo nevada it's like an old-school
clown themed motel in the middle of the
nevada desert on the drive between reno
and las vegas last time i was there
there was a juggalo walking around with
a staff that had an axe on the top of it
just [ __ ] swinging it around and he
got pulled over and arrested but yeah
that's not county for you population
2000. which one's the most overrated
fantastic caverns uh fantastic caverns
is definitely overrated i need to unban
my cameraman nick from their beautiful
underground cave
uh overrated attractions i mean all the
national parks to me are overrated
because they're so full of just annoying
ass people like the grand canyon would
have been so beautiful but you have to
go through so many steps and pass so
many sedona style tourist towns where
you get like taxed a million dollars
before you finally feast your eyes on
the grand canyon and you can't even walk
around without paying a fee it's not
american
this next one is to bomb beyond insanity
the bomb beyond insanity this is a
serious thing
i know this is [ __ ] up
habanero peppers okay chipotle puree i
think i can do this one
there's something about this one wait
you could do this one but you've done
this how many times it's off like 275
okay cool so you're good to go
uh-oh
oh yeah just [ __ ] bad
[Music]
dude yeah that one is a different apron
all together
go for that milk go for that milk
oh god
oh bad i was talking way too much [ __ ]
the grandkids are still proud andrew i'm
sorry to my grandchildren
the bomb beyond insanity is not for me
wow dude yeah you're in tears and i do
this
this sauce
is one that we've kept on the table
since at the beginning of the show
and this is why that is just
non-stop all the time
what did you mean when you said east
coast is not good content people are not
that funny god damn it you waited until
i [ __ ]
when is this gonna go away
it's just gonna keep going
up and up and up
but this is as bad as it's gonna get all
right
the east coast is funny there's people
on the east coast that are funny
but the vast suburbs that comprise the
majority of the population of the east
coast make the east coast not that funny
westchester new york not [ __ ] funny
bryn mawr pennsylvania not funny love
massachusetts not funny long island kind
of funny upstate new york
some laughs
but you gotta really nitpick the funny
east coast guys they're all like 60 plus
years old or they're like under 20.
what makes florida such a content mecca
like the eccentrics that's your favorite
question man it's a problem
florida has a huge mid-level celebrity
influencer culture
jackass uh influenced juggalo adjacent
harm heavy
vegas vacationing contingent
that's florida shout out to mike busey
in the sausage castle that's what i
think of everybody at the sausage castle
has 15 000 instagram followers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bingo psycho hot sauce
warning extreme 15 out of 10 heat it's
all good
i'll just take down some more milk
don't take down any more i'll just take
some more milk no no no no more milk no
more milk
it's all right man
god damn it
[Music]
what's your biggest interviewer pet
peeve when you watch other interviewers
interview
leading questions
like some people would say that you're
the worst rapper of all time how do you
respond to people who would say that
it's like you're the one saying it
this one's more of a tongue blaster
yeah it's coming at you from all sides
the walls are closing in over here no no
no
it's okay
but the good news is
we have made it
to the final wing
the last dab
this is this is your hot sauce this is
our hot sauce it's the last dab we call
it blastab because it's traditional on
here to put a little extra on the last
one you don't have to if you don't want
to and i'd actually recommend you don't
man
[Music]
do you like wiz khalifa's music yeah
like i mean especially like early stuff
get that like kush mixtape you listen to
rap oh you do you know about cushioned
orange juice you're a rap fan yup that's
awesome
because i didn't know if you're just
saying it because you like because you
know what's what interviewers do they
mirror oh right you know about cushion
orange juice
2011 hit mixtape from datpiff.com yeah i
remember the the cover art remember he's
like like pinstripe uh he's in that like
pinstripe suit first time i've ever
smoked weed was to that song
song number eight
i was at a hiding under a slide at a
local playground with six dudes standing
around me being like hit the blood hit
the blood you know
you know what song if you want to make a
weed song right here goes a weird song
still blazing still blazing still
blazing
that guns are flowing so amazing
actually smoking weed to that one was
that um
was that during the trek god days
[Music]
you saved that one for the last wing huh
yeah
so for those who don't know what and who
is trick god well what should we eat
can you
you want me to start rapping huh mm-hmm
i see
you're gonna make me start rapping
aren't you you can see where this is
going number 10 wing shout out to my
grandkids shout out to sean shout out to
brolin shout out to wiz khalifa brian
cranston if you're watching this i love
you and you're acting
down goes
[Music]
there you go
there you go
we have scaled the heights of spice
mountain and gonna put you a little bit
on the spot here to close things out you
know
it's impossible to deny the role that
music plays in your videos it's amazing
no matter where you go or who you're
talking to someone always has bars so
here to close things out i'm curious if
we can take things back with a throwback
trek god freestyle to encapsulate your
experience with the wings of death today
dingo psychosis
[ __ ] i feel like brolin
feel like wiz khalifa
coming with them heaters
i feel like justin bieber
i don't take threats
i do damage
god damn it i'm not from this planet
whoops i meant planted sean is so on
brolin was in this [ __ ] now i'm in this
[ __ ] i'm never throwing in the towel in
this [ __ ]
drank all the milk in this [ __ ] and
look at andrew
taking on the wings of death living to
tell the tales somehow some way even
though there was a second there i
thought we're gonna lose you never that
never that stayed focused stayed strong
and made it all the way to the end now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life oh
[ __ ] well um i'm working on a movie i'm
working on a cartoon i'm working on a
new book
try to get a publishing deal or maybe
i'll do it independently or something
and i'm gonna
release that and go on a book tour
and then yeah hopefully the movie gets
announced soon uh hopefully my cartoon
uh comes out soon and hopefully my book
comes out soon
and hopefully this episode comes out
soon thanks for so much for having me on
it's so freaking fun
good job good job you made it i did
i want to go to a spice conference i'll
go with you you're pretty much like
beyonce at that [ __ ] it's actually
it's actually insane like i can pretty
much move through life you know
uh but not at the hot sauce expo yeah i
just can't imagine walking around with
you oh my [ __ ] god it's shot
[ __ ] i feel like broly
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's video
the season 18 sauces they're here and
you know what that means dom box me
so is the big box the season 18 hot ones
box is now available at heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands
and all of the season 18 sauces
delivered straight to your door in one
convenient box don't forget to be
careful around the eyes
[Music]